our top story this hour west virginia
republicans will have to choose between
two familiar faces when they vote in
primary elections this week the state
once had three congressional districts
but lost a seat following the 2020
census now two sitting members of the
house are pitted against each other for
a shot at one of the remaining seats
alex mooney and david mckinley are both
republicans vying for the state's second
congressional seat and the issue that
most divides them is mckinley's support
of president biden's trillion dollar
infrastructure bill scott mcfarland has
the story
towering above the monongahela river in
star city west virginia stands at
27-foot memorial honoring president john
f kennedy with a bronze statue of the
35th president and a young saluting jfk
jr but much of this state is also a
monument to him i come here to this
state on this occasion asking for your
support kennedy canvassed the mountain
state in his 1960 presidential primary
race seeking and winning a pivotal
victory here and immediately after
taking office kennedy lined west
virginia with a fresh bounty of bridges
bypasses and buildings this goes back to
john f kennedy and through lyndon
johnson and robert c byrd of bringing
federal dollars to west virginia
tuesday is the state's primary election
for the midterms and in one race it's
become clear it's not 1960 anymore two
incumbent republicans running for
nomination for the same redrawn u.s
house seat
one of them is 12-year congressman david
mckinley an engineer and architect who
was one of about a dozen republicans who
voted in favor of congress's trillion
dollar infrastructure plan to provide a
new round of public roads utilities and
broadband
oh my goodness we have probably 40
percent between 30 and 40 percent of
people west virginia get their water
from wells we don't have a distribution
system we have septic tanks all over we
have abandoned bylands
his opponent republican congressman alex
mooney who voted against the
infrastructure bill saying the price tag
was much higher than it needed to be
they want to see us fight for the
conservative agenda roads and bridges
aren't conservative well wasting
taxpayer dollars and indebting our
country is not conservative former
president donald trump opposed the
infrastructure plan and endorsed alex
mooney and he's got a
an opponent but i think mooney's going
to do real well
giving mooney a potential leg up in a
state where trump's popularity might
rival another towering figure west
virginia political analyst happy
kircheval says bringing home federal tax
dollars was typically a political winner
this has all been important and that's
how politicians have run for the year
for many many years cutting ribbons and
traditionally an endorsement from the
state's governor jim justice would move
the needle and justice endorse mckinley
you and donald trump pick different
horses in this race what do you make of
that we can't possibly see things eye to
eye all the time the infrastructure bill
provided this state with billions of
dollars for upgrades but the question is
will a vote in favor of that bill cost
the state's longest serving member of
the u.s house
his job
for cbs saturday morning scott mcfarland
morgantown west virginia